الجديد هي الصوره ذاتها التي تتحدث منذ
خمسه ايام عن عمليه الامل بالحصول على
ناجين او الوصول الى النجين في هذه
المنطقه التي نحن بها في وسط المدينه اذا
امكن بالصوره نجد هذه البنايه المؤلفه من
عشر طوابق التي لازال حتى هذه الساعه يوجد
فيها ما بين 15 الى 20 شخصا تحت الانقاض
مفقودين ايضا بالتوازي اذا ذهبنا اذا امكن
ايضا بهذا الحي مع الصوره الى المقرب
الاخر اذا سمحتوا نجد ايضا كل هذه
البنايات او اغلب البنايات ان لم تكن على
واقفه ومتصدعه ومتخلخله فهي على الارض
وايضا ورائي مباشره
وامامي ورائي من من هذه الجهه وامامي من
الجهه الاخرى نجد ايضا الشوارع التي اطبقت
الابنيه فيها على الارض احمد خليني معك
برايك
نحن صرنا من يوم الاربعاء هون بتقديرك
قديش في اعداد ضحايا بعد ما زالوا تحت
الانقاذ والله لهلا لسه
تقريبا في ارقام اعطوكم اياها والارقام ما
في لا والله قلت لي البنايه التانيه فيها
عائله كامله
وواحد اجى من غرفه قالوا الاولاد بهديك
البنايه لحد اليوم لا زالوا لحد اليوم
اشرح لي هون بس انت عم تشتغل مع الفرق
اشرح لي شو عم يصير يعني هاي الونوش
الكبيره
والالات ماذا يفعلون الان والله يقولون في
صوت ولد هون تحت يحاولون يطلعوه يعني انه
لا يموت
هيدا دقيق يعني البعض قال انه الحساسات
الالكترونيه رصدت اجسام حركه والبعض الاخر
قال انه هذا الامر حتى هذا التوقيت صعب
انت انت على جرافه شو عم يقولوا لكم في او
ما في والله كله بعلم الله الله بيحميه
امبارح طلعنا التاتي ميتين كانوا ثلاثه
ميتين من هاي النقطه
برايك انت اليوم الرابع الخامس الكل يسال
انه هل من الامكان انه يكون بعد في احياء
برايك والله ان شاء الله يكون في احياء بس
مو صدق قليل بالنسبه للعمليات التي الان
تحصل على على هذه الصور المباشره
باستطاعت هؤلاء برايك ان يصلوا ان يصلوا
يعني الى الاحياء او ان يصلوا الى يعني لا
سمح الله هي جثث كيف والله في قلوب في
احياء يمكن يطلع حي والمجسس تانين
اللي يطلع بايدنا نسويه والله هاي بنايه
تسع توافق على بعض من يوم الاربعاء الى
هلا نشتغل اليوم الاربعاء عندك خبر كم جثه
اخرجت
اربعه اربعه
نعم عزيزتي
ايوه محمود